[Music]
my name is Matt Bloomberg I'm a product
manager on the cloud team focused on API
security and I'll be joined today by
Joel DISA who's a security tech lead on
the API security team at Apogee as well
and we're here to talk about api's and
how to design the right architecture to
ensure that your data and users
information can remain secure so I'm
gonna start with an overview of the
power of api's what impact has had on
businesses to date a little bit of the
history there I'll explain why
visibility of your API is important and
what can happen if you don't have that
visibility and then Joel's gonna cover
everything from what the most common
threats that we are seeing in this space
today how architecture has neat hat
needs to evolve from how it was in the
past to how it currently has shifting
with micro services and current future
trends and best practices on how to
secure your api's if you have the cloud
next app you can submit some questions
there and we're happy to answer them at
the end if we have time it's a very
tight schedule today
you're also can step up to the mic and
ask questions so either works you can
also come up to us after the session no
problem
so api's are powering innovation and
just to start with a little bit of the
history there aps have been around for
about 20 years and they were created out
of the need in the early 2000s api's
were first used by companies like Amazon
and eBay who were noticing unofficial
usage of their services and data these
companies needed a way to provide
structure to their developers their
partners and their customers in a secure
way and scalable way and now api's are
everywhere and they're a key enabler to
innovation because they're facilitating
new ways for customers and partners to
interact with with each other
they're also enabling new use cases by
connecting legacy infrastructure to
modern web apps and mobile apps api's
can also enable use cases there's voice
ordering from from a phone to connecting
brick-and-mortar companies moving them
into an e-commerce future and connecting
partners and services so an example here
about talk about Walgreens for a minute
they have thousands of locations
and they're leveraging just to mention a
couple of their API so they have a store
locator API and Fitbit is actually using
that to enable Fitbit customers to
easily locate a Walgreens location and
use Fitbit pay to actually pay in the
stores so there's a couple different API
eyes being used there they also have a
photo printing API and this enables
third-party apps to print to a Walgreens
location and pick up photos in the store
so this is driving customers and traffic
to a retail location and enabling
third-party app developers to have a rev
share model with with Walgreens so so
it's a good win-win situation there but
driving more customers to the stores now
if we take a look at magazine Luiza this
is one of Brazil's largest retailers
they've been around for more than 60
years they realize that it's not only
about physical brick-and-mortar anymore
they wanted to move into the to the
e-commerce space and api's have enabled
them to scale to thousands of delivery
partners and increase their product
catalog from going from 50,000 products
to 1.5 million products so they had a
30x increase in the number of products
by enabling 2,000 merchants to support
and sell their products on their
e-commerce platform as you can see here
the the financial impact has been
incredible so what we're we're seeing
trends from customers in many cases
security is an afterthought it's it's
how do we design the the what are what
are the what are the problems we want to
solve what's the customer requirements
and how do we build that and security is
kind of one more thing they need to deal
with and in many cases an afterthought
and that puts a lot of production user
and data at risk so a lot of the day
that's exposed today we're talking
payment information PII pH I banking
information if you don't have the proper
visibility into this into what is
exposed and how it's exposed you're
creating a lot of risk and liability and
this is why having a full lifecycle API
management solution is really needed to
enable the way secure way of enabling
the exposure of this information so just
to give a high-level overview of what
Apogee is offering
Appaji is an API management platform and
it offers breaks into kind of three
components here from a developer
management perspective we are providing
a secure way for developers to scale
their api's to a larger audience and
consume the information in a managed way
we're offering API analytics which gives
you clear insights to measure tune and
monitor your API program and I'll dive
in a little bit more about the API
monitoring in a few minutes and API
services give you complete control by
allowing you to manage the connection
between the API consumer and the
back-end infrastructure and service so
you can have complete control over the
request and the response so just to give
an example from Google Maps if you
search for a hotel for this week you can
now select choose dates that you want to
check into a room you see the
availability of that room and you can
actually get live pricing data in Google
Maps because this is being powered by
api's from these these up third parties
and this now allows you to book directly
in them in the mobile app or the web app
and/or through thousands of travel
partners so you know Zen hotels kayak
all of these guys have a relationship
with the same region so this is just a
quick example of how powerful api's can
be as opposed to the old world of
manually updating pricing across
different sites and when something is
sold out the time it takes to to remove
those listings so this is this has been
very powerful in Google Maps in search
but you know discussing Walgreens
magazine Luiza and Google Maps
these are a few examples where api's
have been powering business innovation
and disruption in different markets but
in many cases in some cases disruption
is not always a good thing
and when security is an afterthought
sometimes enterprises don't take the
right precautions before exposing their
api's and services and in many cases
it's simply a lack of awareness of
what's exposed what controls are in
place and and what is actually happening
with the data so just to talk a minute
about the USPS and I'm there's no
shortage of these examples I'm just
going to kind of highlight this one and
they offer a new service for their
customers called informed visibility and
this allows businesses and and users to
gain the ability to track near real-time
tracking for mail campaigns so the issue
they had really kind of breaks into two
parts they misconfigured their API and
allowed wildcard input which Joe will
talk a little bit more about input
validation but that that was not the
right way to do it and they also had no
visibility into what data was exposed or
who's accessing that data so the
configuration that they deployed allowed
any user to view or change any other
users information such as the email
address phone number and other PII and
this this is far more harmful than a
single user's account being compromised
if I you know someone hacks into a
single users account they have all of
their data and that's that's obviously
not a good thing but in this case sixty
million users data was exposed for
several months and this could have been
avoided if they'd used proper auth
scopes and simply didn't allow access to
other users data or as Joe will talk
about later input validation where they
simply should not have allowed wild card
input to prevent multiple records from
being extracted and you won't always be
able to prevent every miss configuration
people are human but there are a lot of
processes and methods you can take in an
approach to ensure that these kinds of
things don't happen and again Joel is
going to talk a little bit more about
that but this is another example of why
having visibility into who's accessing
your data is extremely important so it's
just happening too often so there's an
article from dark reading in the first
nine months of last year there were 3600
reported breaches so this isn't just
about the Postal Service and the fourth
largest data breach of the 21st century
was due to an API vulnerability
Gartner's estimating by 2022 so this is
not there's only a couple years out API
abuse will be the most frequent attack
vector resulting in data breaches for
enterprise web applications so with
thousands of breaches last year and keep
in mind outside of the EU with gdpr
they're actually required to report
these breaches but in most of the rest
of the world they're not actually
required to report these on their own so
the number is likely an order of
magnitude higher than
so it really boils down to the fact that
you can't secure what you can't see so
let's just take a quick poll raise your
hand how many people are using api's in
their environment today everybody so
keep your hands up
how many are using an API management
platform about half of those and how
many feel like they have the proper
visibility into their API is 3/4 okay so
you know we did a poll on this a couple
weeks ago and and an overwhelming
majority felt like they did not have the
proper disability and having visibility
into what risk exists and what has
changed is the first step and generally
how well your service is performing and
what threats exist what insider threats
exist what anomalies are you seeing in
your traffic these are all critical
aspects to a successful API program and
every API doesn't face the same
challenges but having that visibility
into rates of attacks and latency of
responses understanding how your
back-end infrastructure is architected
to better educate teams on how to
respond will put you in a better
position if something does happen in the
future
so a patch is taking a two-prong
approach to visibility we're offering
insights to meet the needs of both
operations and security teams so today
users are expecting 100% availability we
talked about five 9s the expectation is
100% and Google research from a couple
years ago more than 53 percent of users
will close a mobile app or leave a
webpage if it takes more than three
seconds to load so the the bars is quite
high and you need to ID be able to
identify issues before your customers do
and as you can see Apogee is offering
clear insights into where requests are
coming from what latency exists by
region you can generate custom reports
and it's always better to be alerted of
issues before your customers alert you
so you don't want to learn about
something saying hey why did the app
installs drop this week or web traffic
drop or why is support having more
customer escalations you want to be
notified before that and for many of our
customers security issues are initially
detected as operational issues so maybe
a large spike in traffic is a good thing
maybe tickets for an event went on sale
or it's a flash sale or something like
that but if it is and this is likely of
concern and something you should know
about Apogee gives you the ability to
take action based on contextual alerts
and before your customers are impacted
so by having access to this data and
leveraging Apogee fault codes you can
easily isolate problems and speed up the
diagnosis quickly so from an API
security reporting perspective Apogee
has has all of the data that security
admins need across various parts of our
platform and we've been seeing an
increasing trend of collaboration
between ops and security teams working
together to investigate and track down
issues so we wanted to make this
information easily accessible with an
at-a-glance view so you can quickly know
if there's something to be concerned
about and we announced this on Tuesday
but we are excited that we are now
offering the API security reporting in
both a dashboard and an API so you can
easily integrate with existing sim tools
that you're using today existing
processes that you already have in place
or in the apogee edge console as this
security dashboard and this is going to
give you everything from changes in
traffic day to day week over week you
can break this down byte in different
time periods get information about
change management and governance data
certificate information policy
configuration data on a per API per
proxy basis information about your
policies so there there is more than 50
elements that are going to be included
as part of this dashboard and this is
now available in alpha today and will be
available more broadly later this
quarter so if we look back at all the
recent data breaches I mentioned if
these organizations had a clear view
into this data security and ops data
there would be many red flags that it
would have jumped out long before an
external researcher discovered that and
so I'm gonna hand things off to Joel and
he's going to talk more about how API
how your secure the security of your
infrastructure is mission critical to
your API s thank you
thanks Matt and thank you all for coming
it's really early and this is a
wonderful conference I hope you're
having fun so many great sessions and
we're really glad that he chose to come
and hang out with us we hope you'll find
this content useful just by way of
introduction my name is Joelle DISA I've
been working for the last 12 plus years
on enterprise security problems and API
is there a key part of your enterprises
IT infrastructure and I thought I'd
spend some time providing a perspective
of where API security is today and
perhaps provide some guidance for where
direction you know for where the future
is headed now security is a very broad
field there are a lot of things to
consider many things to think about and
you could try to wrestle with all of
them at the same time but it's pretty
difficult so what we found is that if
you use data and analytics to understand
the threats that are unique to your API
is and to your environment this will
give you more control and you will be in
a better position to tailor responses to
those trends right and once you have all
the data and metrics laid out you will
find that api's faced threats that are
very similar to typical software
applications as well as web apps right
so you will find everything from basic
software issues things like
authorization problems that were faced
by Equifax and USPS
or maybe something like a random number
generator in your environment that is
not really random or perhaps improper
password storage this is something that
LinkedIn faced in the past and more
recently Facebook right in addition just
like traditional web applications api's
are also subject to injection threats
like cross-site scripting sequel
injection remote code execution and a
whole host of others then there are
service availability issues these are
denial of service issues these can be
caused by militia
actors or just some new release of an
app that's spiking your traffic right
but it could cause a service
availability problem for your api's and
then there's a growing risk from
insiders right a ton of banks technology
companies payment gateways insurance
providers have been compromised by
insider threats and so we talked a
little bit about them today and last by
not but not the least spam and abuse now
if you're following social networks
recently and the security issues that
they're facing they are facing a ton of
spam and abuse and you will see the same
thing with API study and we'll cover
some of that now the first thing you
want to get right is your basic software
architecture and this is something no
one wants to address because it's
difficult but it's actually very
important and key to your enterprises
security so things like good code code
reviews having good tests this will
allow you to reproduce security issues
in your environment fix them and roll
them into production quickly then we
found security reviews to be helpful
just having a review ensures that
security defects found in one part of
your api program don't surface in
another part of the API program and now
a lot of developers today and like a few
years earlier you just read Java and
c-sharp today there's a whole host of
software development stacks right you
can do use node and rails and go and
rust and you know and you should use the
tool that's best suited for your problem
but you must go in with your eyes open
every stack has its own unique security
challenges its own third-party
malnourished process the dependency is
differ and so you must go in with your
eyes open be prepared to address the
security threats that your staff poses
to you right and be aware that they
exist and be prepared to roll them into
production quickly now a lot of security
defects are found by you know
well-meaning users and
customers of your api's right so have a
place for them to reach out to you to
send you an email about the problem
they're seeing build a process to ensure
that you're able to triage these issues
fix them roll them into production and
then get back to the original person who
file it so that they can try it out
again and make sure that the problem is
truly fixed also engaging a third party
penetration test is actually very useful
and that will help you illuminate any
blind spots in your API security posture
and last but not the least another thing
that developers hate is a change
management process ensuring that you
have clear visibility into the changes
happening into your software
infrastructure who is making them why
are they making them what is the real
change and who approved it is someone
even looking into this or just random
change is happening it's also really
important now all of us have to deal
with legacy software and tools and so
what I found useful and you can use that
too it's a draw a threat model something
like the picture here you could use a
sophisticated tool to do this or you
could just draw a simple block diagram
of your infrastructure lay out the
different pieces and just draw the
different dependencies and this will
allow you to do an analysis of what
exactly exists in universe structure
where are the real vulnerabilities and
allows you to measure every component on
each of these parameters and stack rank
them so you can get a handle on on this
aspect of your security now all of this
information or at least some parts of it
will be available in the security
dashboard that Matt talked about and so
you can start from there and continue to
build this up
so let's start one of the most commonly
overlooked but easy to implement changes
is actually just input validation input
validation is one of the best defenses
against injection attacks like sequel
injection cross-site scripting remote
code execution and it's very easy to
build now API is unlike traditional web
applications have an open API
specification or a swagger spec so
there's well-defined input and output so
it's very easy to identify all these
inputs categorize them and just deploy
uniform input validation now there are
two things to think about
one is consistency and two is the use of
share libraries I'll just talk about
them as an example take a look at this
hotel right there are all these rooms
and all these rooms have the same
looking door right now suppose the doors
were different right
and some of them had these push handles
and other handles will these rotate
three types and then there was another
kind of like handle that you could open
the door with and an attacker walked in
and they would look at all these
differences the first thing they would
do is go and try every single door to
try and find any inconsistency that they
could break through right so having a
consistent input validation and layer in
front of your API is actually very
powerful and we're seeing this with our
API as well
Appaji hosts Enterprise the API is for a
ton of customers and the customers that
have sort of inconsistent input
validation or response slightly
differently every single time actually
gets canned the most now the other thing
is the one of the ways to achieve
consistency is to deploy shared
libraries so take a look at this example
in this specification here name tag and
Status are all strings right so explore
the opportunity to see if you can use
the same regular expression and maybe
even the same length just to achieve
consistency use a shared library if you
use a shared library
you know sometimes regular expressions
are hard to write if you fix it in one
place your entire platform will benefit
so it is something you should you should
at least check out try it out and we've
used it successfully API management
vendors like Apogee provide a whole host
of policies that allow you to easily
deploy input validation now if someone
is scanning your API and these policies
trip
all that information will show up on
your security dashboard so you can get a
clear understanding of who is attacking
your API working mobile apps and
well-meaning partners don't trip here
input validation policy it's the rest of
the people trying to actually break in
so you will get a better idea of what's
going on now one of the most common
questions that we get from customers is
how do you deal with service available
tissues or DDoS type situations right
these are very easy to create api's are
out there the specification is known so
anybody can try to maybe cause a
brownout it could also be caused by
buggy clients or maybe partners that
have missed configure their applications
and are causing availability threats and
the best way to defend against api
availability issues and DDoS type
situations is to actually scale out and
the reason that is the case is that if
your infrastructure is able to
successfully defend against a denial of
service attack all the attacker needs to
do
it's just ramped up the traffic right so
you need to scale out now this problem
is not new for google google has been
defending is the infrastructure for
years against denial of service attacks
so there are a whole host of tools that
Google offers that you can use if you
use Google's cloud load balancers these
are the same load balancers that protect
Gmail they scale very effectively and
are able to defend against layer 3 and
below type attacks in addition you will
find that Google's network is one
seamless global network it scales to
handle all of Google's traffic and can
handle yours as well it is equipped with
multiple layers of load balancers that
are all denial-of-service aware so if an
incoming denial of service attack is
sensed these load balancers can drop
traffic before it hits your back-end and
the goal of any successful denial of
service attack is to actually protect
the backend make sure that your API
back-end does not have to deal with any
junk or unwanted traffic now to deal
with API level availability issues you
can deploy some policies from Apogee
Apogee API management provides policies
like API rate limits this will allow you
to smooth any spikes in your traffic in
addition if you deploy Apogee is
globally distributed and encrypted
caches these will help save your API
back-end by serving up responses to
frequent requests an invitation if you
use resource quotas this will allow you
to deploy quotas on a app or client or
partner base and so you can do in a
resource by resource level defend your
defend your API is against there are too
much use now the next thing I wanted to
point out that any of these threats that
face your API is will show up in your
security dashboard so you can get a
better understanding of which API is are
subject to such kinds of threats but one
of the most important things that you
could do to defend your api's against
security threats is actually to protect
the user of those api's and sometimes
this is a hard thing to do and many
people get it wrong and I was hoping to
spend some time on this topic starting
with a history because the space has
undergone a series of changes I thought
I'll take you through a history of those
changes give you a perspective of where
I was coming from and then provides some
direction for where the future is headed
so let's start from the mid-1990s most
websites were you know in the beginning
of the internet were really simple right
and even today most government websites
that just provide information if any way
if you file your taxes recently and went
to the IRS website you'll find it some
thing like this it's a rather monolithic
website most of the content is served
from a content management system or a
simple database and all of this
infrastructure and code is protected
using a network parameter right so it's
very simple but as the internet became
more complicated and websites start
getting more complex multiple websites
were deployed to the same container and
data tiers were deployed to these
containers that allowed these websites
to accept user input and the first user
input obviously was user graduals
usernames and passwords were exchanged
for cookies and again an infrastructure
like this was the was protected using a
network parameter now as these got even
more complicated reusable data
components started getting deployed to
the same container and in order for this
infrastructure to scale multiple parts
of the same kind of layout would deploy
it on a worldwide basis and there was a
concept of sticky sessions right there
still available today sticky sessions
ensure that once you authenticate to a
single part of the infrastructure load
balancers will make sure that all
subsequent traffic from your browser
will hit that same part of
infrastructure and then if those of you
who have worked on WebSphere and web
logic will recognize this where session
ejbs
were deployed to application servers and
that allowed the data tier to scale
independently of the web tier now mobile
apps and stateless uisce using Ajax I
don't know if you if you remember that
that is when things started to shift a
little bit right so if you went to an
airline website in the mid-2000s and
they were rolling out a mobile interface
you would see the shift when you went to
book a flight you would see this
wonderful fluid experience you would see
all the prices laid out dynamically in a
table you could select the dates and you
book a flight and everything was great
and then he went to check flight status
right and that was an older experience
you read it next and it was rather
painful and this was the transition
everyone is making but one aspect was
the jarring customer experience what was
even more jarring was the authentication
and authorization infrastructure
deployed to support such a kind of an
app right so modern stateless UI is
including mobile apps use api gateways
api is tokens whereas traditional web
applications continue to use cookies
right and this difference is what I
wanted to call out now what you'll
notice is throughout this evolution the
underlying security model hadn't really
changed all the data and logic required
to make security decisions was
constrained to that same Network
parameter in many cases it never even
left the JVM and this is starting to
shift this sort of an architecture no
longer makes sense and there was a
reliance on that network parameter and
parameters are good right they give you
peace of mind if you look at this castle
here looks great I would stay in a
castle like that you'll be very secure
it gives you total peace of mind it
enforces consistency it limits the
damage of a breach if that castle was to
blow up infront of the town around it
would ever even feel it and it limits
the number of attacks because it looks
secure so it's nothing wrong with this
but there are a few things you want to
notice about this now 50% of our
customers are moving to using micro
services one thing you want to notice
about micro services is that in
traditional web applications the
applications would deployed to
application servers right but with micro
services and especially if you use
something like spring boot it's the
server that's deployed to the
application so it's actually the other
way around so whereas in an earlier
architecture if you use an application
server the application server handled
authentication authorization session
management but with micro services there
is a need for consistency because it is
now the role of each micro service to
take on that load and if you have you
know thousands of micro services all
deployed to kubernetes clusters on a
worldwide basis to multiple clouds how
do you even draw a parameter and this is
a really big challenge so what do you
want to do is to use an API gateway to
limit the aperture of what you're
exposing and pair it with an identity
management solution to use identity to
manage the relationships between
internal service producers and external
service consumers you may also choose to
deploy a service mesh that will allow
you to compose applications of your
different micro services and as I said
earlier deploy an API gateway to expose
only what's required you also want to
pair this with a highly scalable highly
secure identity management solution now
if you choose to use Google's identity
management platform this will allow you
to deploy a standard consistent
authentication and authorization layer
right it will use standards based
frameworks like worth - and it will also
prevent fraud and abuse because this is
the same infrastructure that defends
Google the systems will detect users
that are malicious that are trying to
break in that are trying to do
credential stuffing by reusing passwords
and will defend against a whole host of
attacks in addition and you should
notice the trend now the metrics
generated by this will tell you who is
attacking your platform and what are you
users actually trying to do are they
legitimate or not
so this is something we highly recommend
everybody do now let me talk about
another remnant of the old cookie based
design right so it was a design that
looked like this a client would
typically take user credentials and
forward them on to a service the service
would then forward them on to an
authentication server to check if the
user was valid it would then check with
an authorization server to ensure that
the user really had the right level of
access
it's very common design pattern nothing
wrong with it now but as these services
start to grow you will see increasing
load on the authentication and
authorization servers even the slightest
latency at that layer will present a
huge latency problem for you in entire
infrastructure in addition there are
single points of failure and one breach
say in service one will actually
compromised your entire infrastructure
because the system does not allow for
time-bound delegated access to data
right so service one has access to all
the credentials if that is compromised
and that service is hosed the entire
infrastructure is gone so what we would
recommend is that everyone move to
something that looks like this it's very
similar but there's more owners put on
the client so your client will now
exchange credentials for an Open ID
Connect identity token with an Open ID
connect server right so the Open ID
connect server will authenticate the
user then it will exchange the identity
token for an access token and the access
token if you use something like auth two
will give you time bound delegated
access only to service one now if you
use a jot token your tokens are very
common nowadays but they basically just
encoded base64 encoded blobs of data
that are signed by the server right so
all the service needs to do is just open
up the token and validate the signature
and now in every request you have all
the information required from a security
perspective to
bleeped the request so the service does
not have to make any outbound calls to
do anything so ja tokens will help your
service scale better what 2 will give
you a consistent authentication and
authorization experience and will
provide you a framework to implement
time bound delegated access to data and
that will limit the breaches and then
you know from a from a you know
traditional architecture point of view
this is what is called as sort of zero
trust right authenticate everyone every
time all the time right so that's what
you might hear commonly as zero trust so
it is a way forward to implement a zero
trust architecture now one of the things
a lot of security folks have to pay
attention to is the user experience
because that's where everything will
break right so if you deploy this
wonderful security and you mess up the
user experience you know that's where
you'll see a breach so this is an
example we were working with with a
retail customer right so retailers have
a whole host of partners that they work
with to be successful and so in this
particular case the partner reached out
to the API team and said hey I want to
access this API and the API team was
super excited and so they contacted the
security team to get a key issue and now
the security team does not have any
context on this so they're trying to
figure out the right scope of access so
they tried to create the right rules and
they meant the key and they hope it's
right and now they have to send the key
over so they would encrypt it using
their PGP key and then send it to a
manager who do the same thing and they
would transfer that to the app developer
who would then use you know an
out-of-band channel maybe call them up
and figure out what the key was and you
know and then finally it would work
until was time to change the scope of
access and then the entire process would
have to be rear old or they had to go
unload the partner revoke their access
and then again there was a mess so a lot
of our customers use what's called a
developer portal right a developer
portal gives API consumers a
self-service experience so that they can
go and check out the api's understand
what is available for access
what is not so that they don't request
the wrong access in this case
mercedes-benz you should check out the
developer portal they've done a
fantastic job right so the developer
portal explains all the aps that are
available what they can do allows the
developer to try it out and then allows
the user to register for a key and you
can then build an approval workflow on
the backend that will allow the right
people to look at the request make sure
it's valid and have a key automated
securely develop delivered to the API
team now again one more thing you want
to call out here is that all the
information from this developer portal
will be made available in the security
dashboard and so you can get a better
idea of who is accessing your API is it
valid or invalid is it malicious or not
is someone poking around your developer
portal just for the fun of it is that
same user has that same user breached
another part of your website so there's
actually a great way to get awareness
into what's happening with your API
program great can I have a show of hands
for how many of you are concerned about
insider threats Wow we did the session
of Tuesday and this is a much bigger
audience and a much better show of hands
insider threats are actually a commonly
overlooked problem but a huge problem
for a lot of enterprises there are a ton
of privileged users that have access to
lots of data and maybe they shouldn't
have if they do maybe they shouldn't use
it unilaterally they should have someone
else you know provide some sort of
approval and they're an increasing
problem for in-store enterprise security
you know time bound delegated access
does not only apply to API
authentication it also employ applies to
your employees and their contractors and
anyone with access to your API program
so what you want to do is the first
thing is integrate your API management
solution as well as your Google cloud
platform with your enterprises single
sign-on infrastructure and that's a
great first start it allows you to
provide a consistent way of looking at
who is doing what in your infrastructure
what are they trying to do like are they
doing something malicious or you know
are they poking around where there
shouldn't be things of that nature and
then the same things you use to protect
your webmail like two-factor
authentication or what have you
risk-based authentication you can use
the same way to protect your API
platform now the second thing you want
to do is to deploy change management
that is to understand who is making what
changes to your API you know what are
the changes why are they being made is
there some sort of a design is there
some sort of an approval so that's some
governance and visibility into what's
happening to your API program and again
we hope to provide some of this
information in the security dashboard it
will give you a good view of the changes
happening to your API and so you can get
a better idea when you integrate it with
your other tools you'll get a holistic
view of the changes happening to your
infrastructure and whether there is some
visibility into it and last but not the
least I wanted to talk about spam and
abuse now again we host a ton of
enterprise api's many of our retailers
are very very concerned about Black
Friday and we see a lot of spam and
abuse especially on high-traffic events
and this is everything from credential
stuffing people just trying to
brute-force the API or just content
scraping for a retailer you know the
price matching is a very big deal so you
might just want a Content scrape to
figure out what's going on and so there
are a whole host of automated actors who
are trying to you know break open the
break open the API there are automated
BOTS that are constantly scanning these
API so any changes now obviously abuse
and BOTS and denial of service are not
new problems to Google and we are
bringing the best of Google to help you
deal with this so there are two draw
Solutions to spam and abuse defense one
is a prevention system that you can
deploy and the other is a visibility
system that it will allow you to get
better visibility in your api's so for
my prevention point of view your goal is
to put maximum onus on the client to
prove who they say they are one of the
best ways again is to authenticate the
users and the clients but we recognize
that a lot of api's today don't need to
be authenticated or maybe authentication
is too high of a barrier so what you can
do is deploy a system like recapture
recapture item if you've noticed it on
many websites it's a simple box with a
checkbox and then it shows up a
challenge and the challenge then slows
down the user they have to actually do
something and so it slows down the rate
of spam and abuse because automated BOTS
can't solve that challenge in many cases
but last year if you don't want that
kind of a disruptive user experience you
know pick out a goat from this map if
you might want to deploy a version three
which was launched last year you should
definitely check it out version three
gives you a reputation score and that
will allow you to make a ton of access
decisions based on the reputation score
and yesterday that same team launched
what's called recapture Enterprise with
a whole host of enterprise ready
features and this if you deploy will
give you a much better idea into spam
and abuse and allow you to take control
of it now the second thing you want to
do is gain visibility Google has a
product called cloud armor if you deploy
this in front of you api's you will get
a better view into the metadata
surrounding your API accesses what are
the IP addresses where are they coming
from what locations can they be blocked
do they have other history so you'll get
a better idea of what is actually
hitting your API endpoints in addition
Apogee has a product called Apogee sense
that does analytics on your API so that
will be allow you to tell you whether
this is a credential stuffing attacks
someone trying to brute force or content
scream and will classify the different
kinds of attacks
get a better idea of what's going on so
we covered a lot of content today I hope
it was useful so I hope it is also clear
that using a data and metrics driven
approach is actually mission critical to
improving your API security and in
addition with the ever-expanding world
of micro services API is mobile apps you
know your architecture really needs to
change in order to improve your security
and keep your users and data safe thank
you very much
[Applause]
[Music]